not in a second but one more question
about the TSA because I don't know why
we can't have airport security like
Israel does nobody want are you kidding
me
I mean answer OHS the size of Delaware
there's like one Airport there they
profile people which we don't allow to
do in this country should we I don't I
don't think we should really know people
in your please people in your and you do
you normally love to do it that's what
you do all day as you should all police
work is profiling to some degree yeah
the problem is people can't keep two
things in their head at the same time
one that the vast majority of Muslims of
course are not terrorists but to most
terrorism comes from Muslims both of
things are indisputably true sure
correct that's correct okay so don't
tell me that the people in your
profession don't profile they just don't
say it out loud well but even the
Liberals who would boo the idea that
we're profiling secretly like that you
people do it but hold on a second we
profile already look we profile already
we profile old people who don't have to
take their shoes off so we've taken a
step in this direction what you're
talking about it's like I I suspect so
what you're talking about is for example
saying in my business Pakistani
Americans Bangladeshi American Somali
Americans these are typically if you
look at terrorism United States or
Europe typically people who might be
susceptible for recruitment 2007-2008
I'm sitting at the FBI
our biggest concern was Somali kids
first generation from Minneapolis
getting recruited to go to Mogadishu so
if you want to sit here in America the
land of the free and the home of the
brave and say I'm gonna put a yellow
star on everybody is that what we're
saying well what are you saying that we
went quite a bit of a leap there to a
yellow star to be to be as you want me
to pick somebody you know what I'm Irish
American yeah if the IRA was conducting
a worldwide jihad against Americans I
would not be upset at all if they pulled
me out of line and just asked me a few
questions as an Irish American I'd
understand that yeah I'm not comfortable
well maybe that's why you don't have a
job